We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% invisible. That's Roman Mars. And this is Stephanie Foo. The pausa and seating area of this building are provided and maintained for the enjoyment of the public
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是斯蒂芬妮·傅。这座建筑的休息区和座椅是由大楼提供并维护的，供公众使用
from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. Privately owned public open space. Popos. P-o-p-o-s. And it has this logo that says public open space and with kind of this little tree that's shaped like a house and all of them have the same logo. The city requires that logo to be on there. It's a cool logo. Yeah. Pretty small sign though. My name's Blaine Merker. I'm an artist and part of a group of artists and designers called Rebar, who are based in San Francisco.
开放时间为上午 8 点至晚上 6 点。私有公共开放空间，简称 POPOS。P-o-p-o-s。它有一个标志，上面写着“公众开放空间”，还有一个形状像房子的树的小标志，所有的标志都长得一样。城市规定必须贴上这个标志。这是一个很酷的标志。是的。不过标志确实有点小。我叫布莱恩·梅克尔。我是一名艺术家，也是旧金山一个名为 Rebar 的艺术家和设计师群体的一员。
Popo, they're a kind of unique set of spaces that were required to be provided by the developer as a condition of approval for the developer's building. So the Popo is around private property. They're owned most likely by the owner of the building. They look like public space, they feel like public space for the most part. This one that we're standing in is granite walkways and the fountain and grass. But technically speaking, these are totally privately owned.
POPO 是一类独特的空间，开发商在获得开发许可时必须将其作为条件提供。因此，POPO 围绕着私有财产。它们很可能归大楼的所有者所有。它们看起来像公共空间，在大多数情况下感觉也像公共空间。我们现在站着的这个地方有花岗岩步道、喷泉和草地。但从技术上讲，这些完全是私人拥有的。
The only catch is that the developer is legally obliged to make this open to the public and to allow anyone to use it. And no one's quite sure what's allowed here, who's in charge, and what the codes of behavior should be. And just because they're public doesn't mean they're easy to find. So this is sort of a strange environment to walk through to get to a public space. Yeah, it's got nice art though. 536 missions. It feels like walking into a library.
唯一的条件是，开发商在法律上有义务向公众开放这些空间，并允许任何人使用。没有人确切知道这里允许做什么、谁负责、行为准则应该是什么。而且，仅仅因为它们是公共的，并不意味着它们很容易找到。所以，要穿过这样一个奇怪的环境才能到达公共空间。是的，不过这里有不错的艺术品。536号使命街。感觉就像走进了图书馆。
You'll see when we walk through the security, like, they'll be this moment where you're like, okay, I just crossed a threshold. Making eye contact with people in authority and sort of acknowledging them, that's not something I ever feel in a park, right? I mean, I don't like walk into the Dolores Park and have to like nod to somebody like, yes, it's okay that I'm here.
当你走过安检时，你会发现，会有那么一个瞬间，你会觉得，好吧，我刚刚跨过了一个门槛。与权威人士进行眼神交流并以某种方式向他们致意，这我在公园里从来没有感觉到过，对吧？我的意思是，我不会走进多洛雷斯公园，还得向某人点点头，仿佛在说，是的，我在这里是合法的。
There's cameras. One, two, three cameras in here. You want to try some badminton? In here? Yeah, why not? Yeah, why not? Yeah, yeah, let's do it. There's a whole set of invisible codes and regulations that shape our behavior.
这里有摄像头。这里有一、二、三个摄像头。你想打羽毛球吗？在这里？对，为什么不呢？对，为什么不呢？对，对，我们开始吧。有一套无形的准则和规定塑造着我们的行为。
Most of us aren't really consciously aware of them. How you hold yourself in public, where you think you can sit down, who you can talk to. It's only by doing something that push back against those codes that you actually can see the codes. Sort of like a scientist firing an electron at an atom to see where it is. If you fire an electron at an atom, you actually change the course of the atom. When you're in one of these spaces, when you start to push back against the code's behavior, you actually change the codes of behavior while you do that. Nothing happened.
我们大多数人并没有真正清醒地意识到它们。你在公共场合的举止、你认为可以坐下的地方、你可以和谁说话。只有当你做出挑战这些准则的事情时，你才能真正看到这些准则。有点像科学家向原子发射电子来观察它的位置。如果你向原子发射电子，你实际上就改变了原子的轨迹。当你身处这些空间之一时，当你开始挑战行为准则时，你在这样做的同时实际上也改变了行为准则。什么都没发生。
Everything happened. Everything was just like, alright. We definitely played long enough probably to be noticed on camera, right? Right. And nobody came. Nobody came. Score one for public space. But if you really want to test the tolerance of a privately owned public open space, bad
一切都发生了。一切都像往常一样。我们打球的时间肯定足够长，以至于在摄像头里被注意到了吧？没错。而且没有人来。没有人来。公共空间记一功。但如果你真的想测试私有公共开放空间的容忍度，打
meant may not be the best test. I mean, if you really want to make someone an authority uncomfortable, the most subversive act especially right now, maybe doing nothing at all. There's a few behaviors that you can sort of plausibly do that allow you to be idle, like fiddling with your phone or smoking or reading a book. But to just lie down and do nothing, not okay. It draws attention to do nothing. The San Francisco Planning and Urban Research Association, which is better known as Burr, has a great guide to all the popos in the city and recommendations about how to improve
羽毛球可能并不是最好的测试方式。我的意思是，如果你真的想让某个权威感到不自在，最具有颠覆性的行为，尤其是现在，可能是什么都不做。有一些行为你可以看似合理地去做，让你能够无所事事，比如摆弄手机、抽烟或看书。但是，只是躺下来什么都不做，这不行。无所事事会引起注意。旧金山规划与城市研究协会（更广为人知的名称是 SPUR）有一份极好的指南，介绍了该市所有的 POPO，并就如何改善
current and future popos, including a proposal to codify some of these rules for the social aspects of privately owned public open spaces. I think it's key to keep in mind that popos will never fully supplant the need for a true comments for true public spaces in a city. Popos can be these great hidden gems and the nooks and crannies of a city, but even if you're allowed to play Batman, the fact that you have to test for it means these spaces aren't really ours. This episode of 99% Invisible was produced by Roman Mars and Stephanie Foo with support from Lunar. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design.
当前和未来的 POPO 提出了建议，包括一项将私有公共开放空间的社会维度的部分规则成文法化的提案。我认为关键是要记住，POPO 永远无法完全取代城市中对真正公共广场、真正公共空间的需求。POPO 可以是隐藏在城市各处角落的绝佳瑰宝，但即使你被允许打羽毛球，你必须对此进行测试的事实意味着这些空间并不真正属于我们。《99%隐形》的这一集由罗曼·马尔斯和斯蒂芬妮·傅制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持。它是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。
To find out more or maybe tell the world about your favorite little private corner of the city, go to 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要了解更多信息或向世界讲述你最喜欢的城市私密小角落，请访问 99%invisible.org。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。